[Music]
foreign
so here today we will revisit the
Pacific Rim universe and showcase 17
kaijus that were not seen in the movies
or the anime series Black some of these
are pretty awesome and deadly so watch
till the end as we will take you deeper
into Kaiju lore than anyone ever has so
let's get to it
number one Meathead seen in the Pacific
Rim Tales From year 0 this is one of the
first avocados to ever emerge from the
bridge and battles to the death against
Horizon Brave the Kaiju has two curved
horns on his head it also has four legs
and a tail that appears to have three
pencils at the end
number two e-chag this is a Kaiju that
emerged from the bridge in July 21st of
2016 and attacked Tokyo but was killed
by a combined effort of two Jaegers
tacit Ronin and Coyote Tango itag is a
kaju with six arms four of which are
appendages with curved blades and it
also has three eyes on each side of its
face its upper body is little more than
a skeletal frame and its skin is black
and on top of its head is a single
narrow horn that is spear-like and
curves upwards
number three reconna this is a very
large kaju that attacked Hong Kong in
2016 and was killed in the city by the
military although not much is known
about its appearance its colors seem to
be bulbous and a small town has emerged
on its skeleton capitalizing on the
Kaiju organ harvesting and also its
worship
number 4 hammerhorn hammerhorn is one of
three kaijus that attacked Australia in
a squad repeater meaning it walks on all
four and has a pale blue skin along with
a long tongue its face features two eyes
on each side and it boasts outward
protruding teeth around its mouth
hammerhorn possesses a robust forehead
with three horns that extend from its
head which it uses as a formidable
ramming tool against its adversaries
especially other Jaegers
number 5 Joe height Joe height is one of
the bipedal kaijus that attacked
Australia characterized by its
crocodilian features it possesses a
sturdy built short legs and elongated
armored arms with three fingers each
including a prominent Central claw to
which it could flip the bird with four
eyes and an extended snout jawhide's
mouth and armor enhances its bite
strength capable of piercing even the
toughest Jaeger armor materials
number six fried crawler fried crawler
is a category 5 kaju and Exhibits a
segmented worm-like body with multiple
legs and small spines on its back what
sets frightcrawler apart from other
kaijus is its bilateral symmetry
featuring a head on each side of its
body remarkably each head commands one
half of the body and functions
autonomously granting frightcrawler the
remarkable ability to regenerate into
two distinct entities if physically
separated
7. Ferno this is one of three kaijus
seen in Pacific Rim shadow dome strike
Ferno is a bipedal kaju that is shown to
be more into the lines of the fire
element as opposed to the other two it
has 5 horns four on the skull facing
backwards and one on the snout like a
rhino and it can spit corrosive saliva
number 8 Tundra this kaju is the
opposite in powers of Ferno while the
farmer is of a fiery nature Tundra as
the name suggests has ice powers and can
breathe an icy freezing breath to attack
humans with it is also by pill with a
rocky armored skin and several sharp
horny Stone outgrowths on the face
number nine Thunderhead this is the
third Kaiju that was seen in the Pacific
Rim shadow dome strike it is also by
Peter and nature and has a segmented
armor-like skin it also possesses Four
Eyes a very big mouth and two curved
horns its special abilities of powers is
electromagnetic emission kinda like that
of leatherback which it can use to
disable electronic equipments including
those that are seen in the Jaegers
number 10 himantura this kaju known as
himantura is an unrealized Concept in
the Kaiju Universe it was created but it
was unused it is said that hemantura is
a fusion of a stingray and a switchblade
making it the most extraterrestrial
looking Kaiju among all of them
resembling that of the precursors
himatura has the unique ability to fold
or expand its body creating the illusion
of being three distinct creatures within
one
is also called Thunderhead for some
reason but predates the one seen in the
shadow dome strike it seems to possess
long tentacles or maybe it was arms that
it uses to swim at high speeds seen in
the comics Tales From The Drift this
kaju attacks are submersible that was
tracking it as it emerged from the
bridge but it was later killed by
brawler Yukon after a devastating fight
number 12 rachnid racknet is a Kaiju
that looks kind of like an ant with six
arms equipped with sharp claws that
emerge in 2024 it emits a bioluminescent
blue light all around its body which
primarily emanates from its abdomen and
thorax ragnet's head stands out with a
massive jaw comprised of 19 parts and
has a total of 28 eyes
number 13 spying Jackal this is a
category for Kaiju that emerged and
attacks Sydney but was later killed by
Striker Eureka spine Jackal was a tall
grayskin kaju with bioluminescent traces
emitting from its mouth and its
countless eyes and when I say counters
there are a lot of them it also has a
jaw with mandibles and it also walked
upright
number 14 sulfuri sulfuri is a kaju of
an undetermined category and attacks
Seattle sulfuri is a bulky brown kaju
with thick skin and two blue eyes and on
his head it has six horn-like structures
in his body it has four arms and plates
on their elbows it was killed in the
city but the Jaeger that defeated it was
for some reason unknown
number 15 tarantulas this is a category
3 Kaiju and is a decapital monster with
spider-like traits meaning it has 10
arms its body is around and green skin
with a bumpy texture on the surface of
its lower back it has five pairs of
segmented legs that have sharp ends it's
faced has a total of eight eyes four
small ones in the front and one large
eye on each side and a set of pincers
near its mouth
number 16 veroceter this okay this is a
simulated Kaiju and not a real one but
we will also include this one and
another one in this list it appears in
the Jaeger Academy for recruits to train
with while simulating Jaeger piloting it
appears to look reptilian with large
mouth and four legs as well as having a
very long tail its body is filled with
sharp spines and bony outgrowths
and number 17 bellabong this is another
simulated kaju seen in the Jaeger
Academy it is set for the same role as
the other one billabox appearance is
different though it is a mixture of a
crustacean and an insect its broad shell
protects everything from the head down
it walks on multiple short legs and uses
pincers as a means to attack its enemies
during melee combat especially the
Jaegers
so that's all we have on the 17 missing
kaijus from the Pacific Rim movies and
the anime so these are seen in comics
and other words basically so I hope you
have enjoyed watching this video do hit
the like button for support and
subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates or new
videos right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam